Okay.
Where are we?
Today we're going to study,
I'm going to talk about Aristotle's,
Aristotle's comparative politics
and focusing on the idea of the regime.
This is the theme that you
remember in the opening day. Uh,
I said was really the central concept
or the leading thread of this,
of this course,
and it's in books three through six of
Aristotle's politics that he develops.
Uh, his, his idea of rich,
of the regime and regime politics books
book one that we spoke about last time
really in a way tells us
something about the, uh,
you might say almost the metaphysics
of Aristotle's politics today.
Aristotle speaks more empirically,
more politically about what a regime is.
Yeah.
His idea of regime [inaudible] again,
the same word,
the same word that was used for the title
of Plato's Republic is the centerpiece
of Aristotle's politics.
Literally,
it occupies the, the theme of the
third of the middle three books,
books three through six.
These books are difficult in many ways.
They're complicated.
They're not everybody's
favorite part of the book,
but they are my favorite part because
it tells us more precisely than anywhere
else.
How Aristotle understands the nature
of politics in that after all,
it's what we are most interested in.
A regime refers to both the formal in
numeration of rights and duties within a
community,
but it also addresses something closer
to what we would call the way of life or
the culture of the people. There
are distinctive customs, manners,
laws, habits, moral
dispositions and sentiments.
And Aristotle's constitutional theorizing
begins by asking a simple question,
what is the identity of a city?
What?
What gives it its identity and
enduring existence over time?
And his answer is the regime.
The regime is what gives a
people in the city its identity.
Aristotle distinguishes between what
he calls the matter and the form of the
regime.
Let me examine both of these.
In turn, the matter, the substance,
the material basis of the regimes
concerns it's citizen body.
That is to say the character
of those who constitute a city.
And here he reject a number
of alternatives for what
constitutes a citizen body.
He rejects the idea that the city is
defined simply by a group of people who
inhabit a common territory,
the same space as it were.
The identity of a Paul as he writes,
is not constituted by its walls at is to
say it is not constituted by geography
alone.
And similarly,
he rejects the idea that a regime can
be understood as a defensive alliance
against invasion by
others. Uh, in our terms,
for example,
NATO would not be a regime,
a purely military or defense of alliance.
And finally,
he denies the possibility
that a regime exists,
that whenever a number of people come
together to establish commercial relations
with one another,
uh,
organizations like Nafta or the WTO,
the World Trade Organization,
do not a regime make a regime
cannot be understood simply as a,
as a commercial, uh, alliance.
What is a regime then?
It is evident. Aristotle said, this is it.
A city is not a partnership in a location
or for the sake of not committing
injustice against one another
or for transacting business.
So what is a citizen body?
Okay.
The citizens who constitute a regime.
He tells us do more than
occupy a common space,
but are held together according to
Aristotle by bonds of common affection.
It is affection,
loyalty,
and friendship that make up a regime.
This sort of thing.
He says this political partnership
is the work of affection.
Phi Leah is,
his word is the work of affection for
affection is the intentional choice of
living together 1288
if anyone's interested.
It is the intentional
choice of living together.
Friendship he writes is the
greatest of good things for cities,
for when people feel
affection for each other,
they are less likely
to fall into conflict.
But what kind of friendship
is he talking about?
Is it the kind of friendship that,
uh,
you feel for your best friend
or for your parents or siblings?
What kind of friendship are these bonds
of affection that he says holds the city
together and that make it a regime?
Political friendships he tells us are not
the kind of thing that us to forgo our
own individual identities in the way that
one might find in passionate relations
of love.
Right?
We had did they presuppose relations
that is to say political relations,
not between lovers or even
best friends of some kind,
but between civic partners who may
in fact be intensely rivalrous and
competitive with one another for positions
of political office and honor civic
friendship, civic five Leah
is there, in other words,
not without a strong element of what
might be thought of as sibling rivalry in
which each citizen strives to outdo the
others for the sake of this civic good.
Many of you have siblings and know a
little bit about what sibling rivalry is
like siblings is,
everyone knows maybe the best of friends,
but this does not exclude
strong elements of competition,
rivalry and even conflict for
the attention of the parents
and fellow citizens for Aristotle are
like siblings each competing with one
another for the esteem,
the affection and the recognition of the
city that serves for them as a kind of
surrogate parent.
That is the way that Aristotle
understands a civic body, a citizen body,
so that when he says that citizens are
held together by Chi ties of common
affection,
he means something very specific.
The civic bond is more than an aggregate
of mirror self interest or rational
calculation as was going to be defended
by someone like Thomas Hobbes or by most
of today's modern economists who believe
that society can be understood simply
as a series of rational transactions
between buyers and sellers of different
goods and that can be modeled along
some kind of game theoretic lines.
Aristotle denies this,
explicitly denies this.
He seems to have known something about
the modern economic theory of society
long before modern economics
was even developed.
But again,
when Aristotle speaks of the kinds
of affection that hold a citizen body
together,
he does not mean anything like the bonds
of personal intimacy that characterize
private friendships.
What he means when speaking about civic
affection is more like the bonds of
loyalty,
camaraderie that hold together
members of a team or a club.
These are more than,
again, ties of mutual.
They require loyalty.
Trust.
What social scientists today
sometimes call social capital.
That successful societies
requires social capital.
A distinguished political
scientist at another university.
I will not mention its name
here at another university,
has spoken about the importance of social
capital or trust as the sort of basic,
uh, relation, the basic component of a,
of a healthy democracy.
Aristotle knew that he didn't,
he didn't use a kind of ugly social
scientific word like social capital.
Rather, he spoke about civic
friendship and Phi Leah,
the political partnership, he
says, must therefore be regarded
as being for the sake of noble actions
and not just for the sake of living
together. The city, as
he likes to say, exists,
the regime exists not
merely for the sake of life,
but for what he understands
to be the good life,
the life of friendship,
that life of, again,
competitive relations for
positions of honor and office.
So we can say that a regime is in the
first instance constituted by its citizen,
but it's citizen bodies. Citizens are
those who share a common way of life,
the citizen in an unqualified sense.
Aristotle writes is defined by no other
things so much as sharing in decision
and office
or as he puts it a little bit later.
Whoever is entitled to participate in
an office involved in deliberation or
decision making is a citizen of the city.
Listen to the words he uses
there in describing the citizen.
A citizen is one who takes sharing in
decision in office who participates in
deliberation and decision
making as citizen is one.
Therefore who not only enjoys
the protection of the law
is not merely you might
say a passive beneficiary of the
protection of society and its laws,
but is one who takes a share in shaping
the laws and who participates in
political rule and deliberation.
Aristotle even notes,
you probably observed that
his definition of the citizen,
he says it's most appropriate to
citizens of democracy were in his famous
formulation. Everyone knows how
to rule and be ruled in turn.
It is this reflection and the character
of the citizen that leads him to wonder
whether the good citizen in the good
human being are one and the same.
Can One, can a person be
both as it were, a good man,
a good person and a good citizen?
Famous discussion in Aristotle's book,
Aristotle answer to this is
perhaps deliberately obscure.
The good citizen he tells us is
still relative to the regime.
That is to say the good
citizen of a democracy,
well not necessarily be the same person
or the same kind of person is the good
citizen of a monarchy or an aristocracy
citizen virtue is relative or we might
say regime relative only in
the best regime. He says,
well the good citizen and the
good human being be the same,
but what is the best regime,
at least at this point he has not told us.
The point he's trying to make is
there are several kinds of regimes and
therefore several kinds of
citizenship appropriate to them.
Each regime is constituted by it's matter.
That is to say by its citizen
body as we've been talking about,
but also now by its form,
by its formal structures.
That is to say every regime will also
be a set of institutions and formal
structures that give shape to it.
Citizens regimes or constitutions,
you might say our farms or formalities
that the determine how power is shared
and distributed amongst
citizens. Every regime, uh,
is an answer, uh, consciously or,
or not to the oldest political
question of all who governs who,
who should govern.
Every regime is an answer to that question
because every regime sets forward a
way of distributing formally distributing
powers and distributing offices among
its citizen body. So we move now
from the matter of the regime.
It's what constitutes its citizens and
its citizen body to the question of the
form of the regime. It's
forms, it's formalities,
its structures and institutions.
You might say
entirely too much of modern political
science is focused on simply the forms and
formalities of political life.
Not Enough in my opinion,
with questions of the
citizen body and what makes,
what constitutes the character or
the virtue in Aristotle's term of its
citizens.
But nevertheless,
Aristotle gives extraordinary
importance and attention to the forms or
formalities that make up a regime.
What, what does he mean by that?
Aristotle defines this
strictly formal criteria,
other polity or twice in his politics.
And I'm sure you noted both
times where they appeared. Yes.
Yeah.
Book three chapters,
six famous definition.
The regime he says is an arrangement of
a city and arrangement of a city with
respect to its offices,
particularly the one who has the
authority over all matters for what has
authority in the city is everywhere.
The governing body and the
governing body is the regime.
The regime is an arrangement of a city.
He says with respect to
its offices in every city,
we'll have a governing body.
That governing body being the regime.
The second definition
appears at the beginning of book four
chapter one for a regime he writes is an
arrangement in cities connected with
offices establishing the manner in which
they have been distributed,
what the authoritative element of
the regime is and what the end of the
partnership is.
In each case
a similar but slightly different
definition of what constitutes the formal
structure of regime politics,
but from these two definitions
appearing in book three Chapter Six and
book for Chapter One we learned a number
of important things.
First is to repeat a regime concerns
the manner in which power is divided or
distributed in a community.
This is what Aristotle means when he
uses the phrase in arrangement of a city
with respect to its offices.
In other words,
every regime will be based on some
kind of judgment of how power should be
distributed to the one to the few or the
many to use the Aristotelian categories
of political rule or, or
some mixture. Uh, some,
some mixture of those three classes that
constitute every city in every regime.
One of these groups he says will be
the dominant class will be the dominant
body,
the ruling body,
as he says in that definition
and that ruling body will intern.
He says,
define the nature of the regime.
But Aristotle tells us something
more than this. A regime,
his regime topology is to say his division
of power is division of regimes into
the rule of the one,
the few and the many is based not
only on how powers are distributed,
that's purely factual base way.
He also distinguishes between
regimes that are well ordered,
well governed and those that are corrupt.
Uh,
those that are well, those
that are corrupt, what,
what does he mean in
terms of this distinction?
Aristotle's distinction is now
seems to be not only empirical, uh,
again, based on the factual
distribution of powers,
it seems to have a non at what we,
what we might call today a
normative component to it.
It makes a distinction or a judgement
between the well ordered in the deviant
regimes, the corrupt
regimes. On the one side,
he tells us the well ordered
regimes are monarchy,
aristocracy and what he calls polity
rule of the one, the few and the many.
And on the corrupt side he calls,
he describes them. Is Tyranny,
oligarchy and democracy also ruled
by the one, the few and the many.
But what criteria we want to know does
he use to distinguish between these,
uh, as it were six fold a
classification of regimes.
How does he distinguish the well ordered
regimes from the corrupt regimes?
And here is where Aristotle's analysis
gets in some ways maddeningly tricky,
uh,
because in many ways of his general
reluctance to condemn any regime out of
hand. If you were to read, uh,
more than I had assigned for you in class,
if you were to read throughout,
through, through all of
books, six, for example,
you would find Aristotle not
only giving advice to Democrats,
uh, democracies and other regimes
on how to preserve themselves.
You would find a lengthy
discussion description of how,
of how tyrants should,
uh,
moderate or how tyrants learn to
preserve and defend their own regime.
It seems as if it seems almost as if
living before the incarnation of pure evil
in the 20th century with the
rise of modern totalitarianisms,
that Aristotle seems to think
that no regime was so bad.
No regime was so devoid of goodness that
its preservation was not worth at least
some effort.
Think of that rather in many ways he
provides reasoned arguments for the
strengths and weaknesses of
several different regime types.
But consider, uh, the one that's
closest to our own democracy,
let's consider what Aristotle
has to tell us about that regime.
In fact, it would be an interesting
question for people to consider. Uh,
do you know how would Aristotle,
uh,
confront or what would his analysis
be of a regime like Hitler's Germany,
uh, Stalin's Russia,
the around of Khomeini,
uh, regimes that, uh,
are clearly tyrannies,
but do they even go beyond in some way
the tyrannies that Aristotle spoke about?
And what kind of advice,
what would he,
what would he have to say about them in
any way? Let's think about democracy.
Interestingly,
we find Aristotle defending democracy
on the grounds that it may contain
collectively greater wisdom
then originally am ruled
by the one or the fuel.
In Book Three, Chapter 11,
for example, he writes for,
because they are many,
that is to say the citizen body,
the ruling body of a democracy,
each can have a part of virtue and
prudence and on their uniting together and
under joining together,
he says the multitude with its many
feet and hands and having many centers
becomes he writes like
a single human being.
And so also with respect
to character and mind,
think of that the people in a
democracy, he says, coming together,
uniting together,
become like a single human
being with many hands and feet.
And he says with greater
character in mind,
we even here more than
any single individual.
And in the same text we
also hear Aristotle praising
the practice of ostracism.
That is to say exiling banishing goes
individuals deemed to be preeminent in any
particular virtue or quality.
And he makes a similar
point in book three,
Chapter 15 and describing the
process of democratic deliberation,
uh, as a superior means
of arriving at decisions.
He compares it to a potluck dinner.
Any one of them,
he says that is to say any one of the
citizens taken singly is perhaps inferior
in comparison to the best,
but the city is made up of many
persons just as a feast to which many
contribute. It's finer is better
than a single and simple one.
And on this account,
a crowd also judges many matters
better than a single person.
Furthermore, what is many he
says is more incorruptible,
like a greater amount of water? The many
is more incorruptible than the fuel.
So he gives, they're a powerful
argument in defense of democracy,
like a potluck dinner,
each individual cook may not
be as good as the best chef,
but many taken together will provide
many more dishes in many more.
A variety of for a variety of tastes.
Then does a single chef.
And he says, furthermore, a crowd,
the many is more in
incorruptible than the few,
uh, less light, an incorruptible.
Here I take it in a kind of
ordinary sense of the term,
less susceptible to bribery.
You can't bribe a lot of people in the
way that you can a single individualistic
or Aristotle's views on democracy.
Correct.
Here in his analysis,
uh,
do in fact many chefs make for a
better dinner than a single chef.
Uh, well, no, no.
Would you rather have dinner at the Union
league and there's one chef or master
chef?
What would you hear there?
Have dinner with a bunch of your
friends each providing some piece of the
dinner. Wow. It's a good arm.
Gets an interesting argument.
It's open to debate it at any rate.
Yet at the same time
is Aristotle is seen defending democracy
and providing reasoned and in many
ways,
sensible arguments for democratic regimes.
You find him in the same section of the
book providing a defensive kingship.
And the rule of the one
in book three, Chapter 16,
he considers the case of the king who
act in all things according to his own
will. One's like a kind of
absolute monarch of some kind.
This is the part of Aristotle's politics.
It seems closest in a way to the
idea of a platonic philosopher,
King King,
who rules without law and rules for the
good of all simply on the basis of his
own superiority.
Aristotle coins a term for
this kind of king overall.
He calls it the Pan Boster layer,
Basa layer being the Greek word for king,
uh, like the name. You know, people
like the name Basel Bazell Basel.
It's the Greek word for king
and a pan meaning universal,
uh, pan buster layer, the universal king.
The King of our Aristotle does not rule
out the possibility of such a person,
uh, emerging a person of what
he calls excessive virtue,
almost hyperbolic excellence.
He says,
who stands so far above the rest as to
deserve to be the natural ruler overall.
But how we want to know does Aristotle
reconcile his account of the pound Bazza
layer,
the king of overall with his earlier
emphasis upon democratic deliberation and
shared rule,
the citizen recall is one who
takes turn ruling and being ruled.
In turn,
when readers look at
Aristotle's account of kingship,
and particularly this notion of the
pond Basa layer, the king overall,
the suggestion must at least occurred
that there is a hidden Alexandrian or
Macedonian streak to Aristotle's political
thinking that owes more to his native
mastodon than to as adopted Athens.
The idea of universal kingship.
Think of Alexander the
great later on and in fact,
in one of my favorite
passages in the book,
which you will read for next time,
uh,
I cannot resist quoting already a passage
from book seven and near the end of
the book, book seven Chapter Seven
or Aristotle writes as follows,
he writes to the nations in cold
locations and Kolbe locations,
particularly in Europe,
are filled with spiritedness.
There's that platonic word again through
most are filled with thumos but lacking
in discursive thought, lacking in the
deliberative element. In other words,
hence they remain free
because they're through modic,
but they lack political governance.
Those in Asia,
on the other hand, he writes thinking,
probably hear of Persia, Egypt,
places like Egypt and Persia have
souls endowed with discursive thought,
but lack spiritedness lack thumos.
Hence they remain ruled and enslaved.
But then he goes on to
say the stock of Greeks,
Sharon both just as it holds,
he says the middle in
terms of location for itch.
That is to say the
Greeks are both spirited,
are both through modic in endowed with
deliberative thought and hence remain
free and governs itself
in the best manner.
And he writes and he concludes at the
same time is capable of ruling all should
it obtain a single regime that these
Greeks are capable of ruling all he says
all who is all, what do you mean
by the all here, the Greeks,
the rest of the world, uh, should are,
are capable of attaining it seems
as single hegemony a single regime,
uh, are if in fact circumstances, uh,
develop.
So here is a passage in which Aristotle
clearly seems to be pointing to the
possibility of a kind of universal
monarchy under Greek rule
as at least as a,
as a possibility.
And this passage I read at length,
uh,
is important, uh, for a number
of reasons. Let me just, uh,
try to explain
in the first place,
it provides us with crucial information
about Aristotle's thinking about the
relations of impulse and reason of Thumos.
And reason,
as you might say,
the determinants of human behavior
are the crucial path term in
that passage is this again,
this platonic term spiritedness which
is both a cause of the human desire to
rule and at the same time a because of
our desire to resist the domination of
others,
it is the unique stores
of human assertiveness and
aggressiveness as well as the
source of resistance to
the aggression of others.
It's a very important psychological
concept and understanding politics.
And second,
the passage tells us something about
certain additional factors extra in many
ways,
extra political factors such as
climate and geography as components.
Uh,
in the development of political society.
Apparently apparently qualities such as
through most and reason through most and
deliberation are not distributed
equally and universally.
He says he distinguishes between
the peoples of the north,
he calls them the Europeans,
spirited and warlike but lacking
through most those of Persia and Egypt
containing highly developed
forms of intellectual knowledge,
no doubt,
thinking about the development of things
like science and mathematics and Egypt,
but lacking this quality of most,
which is so important for self government,
for self rule. These are one
might think about this. These,
these things he says are at least in part
determined by certain kinds of natural
or g geographic and
climatic, uh, qualities.
Uh,
a modern reader of this passage that
comes to mind is a skew in the spirit in
his famous book,
the spirit of the laws with its emphasis
upon the way in which geography and
climate and environment,
uh,
become impart determinants of the kind
of political culture and political
behavior exhibited by different peoples.
And finally, this passage tells us
that under the right circumstances,
at least Aristotle suggests the Greeks
could exercise a kind of universal rule
if they chose.
He does not rule out this possibility.
Perhaps it testifies to his view that
there are different kinds of regimes that
may be appropriate to different kinds
of situations to different situations.
There is no one size fits
all model of political life,
but good regimes may come
in a variety of forms.
There seems to be at least built in
to Aristotle's account of politics,
a certain flexibility, a certain, uh,
latitude of discretion that in some kit
Kat passages even seems to border on a
kind of relativism.
But nevertheless,
Aristotle understands that a person,
this pond Basilea this person of
superlative virtue is not really to be
expected.
Politics is really a matter of dealing
with less than best circumstances,
which is perhaps one reason why Aristotle
gives relatively little attention to
the structure of the best regime.
Such a regime which I do
want to talk about tomorrow.
Wednesday is something to be
wished for but is not, uh,
for practical purposes. Something to
which he devotes a great deal of time.
Most regimes,
and for the most part we'll
be very imperfect mixtures
of the few and the many,
the rich and the poor.
Most regimes for the most part,
most politics for the most part will
be struggles between what he calls
oligarchies and democracies ruled by
the rich oligarchies ruled by the poor
democracies.
And that respect,
Aristotle seems to add an economic or
sociological category to the fundamentally
political categories of few.
And many.
The few are not simply
defined quantitatively,
but they are defined as it were
also sociologically the rich,
the poor again defined as the many
again defined by him as the poor.
It was not. You have to see
when you read these passages,
it was not Karl Marx,
but rather it was Aristotle
who first identified the
importance of what we would call
class struggle and politics.
Every regime is in many ways
a competition between classes,
but where he differs from Mark's right
where he differs is not is he believes
that the fundamental form of
competition between classes,
it's not just for resources.
It is not a struggle over who controls
what Marx calls the means of production.
It is a struggle over positions of honor,
of status and position
of positions of rule.
Struggle is in short political struggle,
not economic struggle.
Every regime he believes it will be in
some ways a site of Qantas station with
completing,
with competing claims to justice with the
competing claims to political rule for
who ought to rule.
There is, in other words, not only
a partisanship between regimes,
but partisanship within regimes
where citizens are activated,
different groups of citizens,
different classes of citizens are
activated by rivalrous and competing
understandings of justice and the good,
the Democratic faction he tells us
believes because all are equal in some
respects they should be equal.
In all respects,
the oligarchy tells us because
people are unequal in some respects.
They should be unequal in all respects.
For Aristotle,
the point and purpose of political science
is to mediate the causes of faction
to help causes affection that
lead to revolution and civil war.
Aristotle's statesman,
Aristotle state craft is political.
Science is a form of political mediation.
How to bring peace to
conflict ridden situations.
And it's always surprising to me that
many people think that Aristotle ignored
or has no real theory of political
conflict when it seems to me conflict is
built in to the very structure of his
understanding of a regime. And again,
not just conflict between rival regimes,
but conflict built into the nature of
what we could call domestic politics,
different classes contending with
different conceptions of justice.
And how can political, how can the
political scientist to bring peace,
bring,
uh,
bring moderation to these deeply
conflict ridden situations.
Uh,
Aristotle proposes,
how does he to pros to do this?
He proposes a couple of remedies to
offset the potentially warlike struggle
between various factions.
And the most important of these
remedies is the rule of it.
Law Law
ensures he says the equal treatment of
all citizens and prevent arbitrary rule
at the hands of the one the few or the
many law establishes what he says is a
kind of impartiality for law.
He says his impartiality one
who asks the law to rule.
You said it's in book three.
Chapter 16 is held to be acting is held
to be asking God and intellect alone to
rule.
Why one who asks,
man asks the beast desire
is a thing of this sort.
And spiritedness.
He writes again through most spiritedness
perverts rulers and the best men and
to law is intellect,
appetite,
even the best men he says can
be perverted by spiritedness.
Uh,
law is the best hedge we have against
the domination of partiality and desire.
But this is not the end of the story.
In fact, it is only the beginning.
Aristotle raises the question,
very important question,
whether the rule of law is to be
referred to the rule of the best,
the best individual.
And typically again, he,
he seems to answer the question from
to two different points of view.
Giving each perspective
it's, it's do, it's justice.
He begins in many ways by appearing to
defend Plato's view about the rule of the
best individual. The best regime he
says is not one based on written blah.
Okay
law. And there's a reason it seems to
be something like this. Law is at best,
a clumsy instrument,
a clumsy,
clumsy tool because law is only deal
with general matters and cannot deal with
particular concrete situations for their
more law seems to bind the hands of the
statesmen and legislators who always have
to be responding to new and unforeseen
circumstances.
And yet at the same time,
Aristotle makes the case for law
the judgement of an individual,
no matter how wise is more corruptible,
whether due to passion or interest or
simply the fallibility of human reason.
Then as law,
he notes as a practical matter,
no one individual can oversee all things.
Yeah.
Only a third party in this case law,
uh,
is capable of judging adequately.
Again,
he seems to give reasons and
good reasons for both cases.
So he, but he moves to the question,
should lobby changed his law changeable?
And if so, how? And once again,
he puts forward different arguments
in book two, Chapter Eight,
he compares law to other arts and
sciences and suggest was sciences such as
medicine and uh, his exhibited
progress. This is true.
This should be true for law.
The antiquity of a law.
A alone is no justification for its usage.
Aristotle seems to reject a,
you might say Burkey and conservatism,
uh,
long before the time antiquity or
tradition alone is no justification.
Yet. At the same time, he, he seems
to recognize that changes in law,
even when the result is
improvement are dangerous.
He writes it as a bad thing to habituate
people to reckless disillusion of laws
for the city will not be benefited as
much from changing law is it will be
harmed through being habituated
to just obey the rulers.
In other words,
he's saying lawfulness like
every other virtual is a habit.
It's a habit of behavior and the
habit of destroying, disobeying,
even an unjust law will make
people all together lawless.
This emphasis upon law is a constraint
on human behavior in many ways.
Seems to introduce a strong element of
conventionalism in Aristotle's thought.
Okay. This is the view that justice
is determined by laws, by customs,
traditions that are just conventions.
No,
most in the broadest sense of the
term that constitutes justice.
And as I indicated,
there's also seems to be a certain degree
of relativism associated with this.
Since conventions vary from society to
society to standards of justice will seem
to v to again be regime dependent and
this seems to be entirely consistent with
parts of Aristotle's anthropology.
After all,
if we are political animals by nature,
then the standards of justice must
derive from politics are right.
That's transcends.
Society cannot be a right natural to man.
Yet Aristotle's conception
of our political nature
seems to require standards of
justice that are natural or right for us.
Rule of law presupposes that there was a
form of justice or right natural to us.
But what is the Aristotelian
Standard of natural,
right or natural justice?
Aristotle makes it surprising assertion.
Uh,
unfortunately it's an
assertion and a book.
You're not reading a book,
the Nicomachean Ethics Book Five,
Chapter Seven,
he says there that all natural,
right is mutable, are changeable.
All standards of natural
justice are changeable.
And by this he means that natural right
is revealed not in general propositions
or universal maxims is for example,
Emmanuel.
Kant would argue later on,
but in the concrete decisions of a
community or its leaders about what is a
right or wrong,
natural right is mutable because different
circumstances will require different
kinds of decisions.
Okay,
so does this mean then that for Aristotle,
there are no universally valid
standards of justice or right?
Did it all depends on that justice
like the good citizen is as it were,
regime dependent.
Is this not to fall into the boundless
field of machiavellianism that declares
right and wrong to be entirely
relative to circumstance?
Context dependent? Is that what
Aristotle is saying? Not at all.
Aristotle emphasizes the mutable character
of natural right in part to preserve
the latitude of freedom of
action required by the Statesman.
Every statesmen must confront new and
sometimes extreme situations that require
inventiveness and creative action and in
such situations where the very survival
of the community may be at stake,
we might call these emergency situations.
The conscientious statesmen must
be able to respond appropriately.
Nine 11 for example,
a moral law that refused to allow the
statesman to protect the community in
times of crisis would not be
a principle of natural, right?
It would be a suicide note.
Okay?
To considerable degree,
Aristotle, Aristotle,
helion standards of natural right
reside in the specific decisions,
the concrete decisions
of the ablest states.
These cannot be determined in advance,
but must be allowed to emerge
in response to new and again,
different in unforeseen situations.
What does naturally right,
what is it right? By nature in
peacetime will not be the same.
It is what is naturally right or
right by nature in times of war,
okay?
What is right in normal situations will
not be the same as what is right in
states of emergency.
The Statesman in the areas to telian
sense is the one who seeks to return as
quickly and efficiently as
possible to the normal situation.
And this is what distinguishes Aristotle
from Machiavelli and all those later
thinkers who take their
bearings from Machiavelli.
I'm thinking of thinkers like hubs like
Carl Schmitt and Max Weber's in the 20th
century. All of these thinkers take their
bearings from the extreme situation,
situations of civil war,
of social collapse,
of national crisis.
The Aristotelian statesmen will not be
unduly affected by the occasional need to
depart from the norm.
Whether this means just to spend in the
case and to take an American case. Uh,
the suspension of Habeas Corpus
is Abraham Lincoln did in the,
uh,
during the civil war or the regrettable
need to engage in domestic espionage.
But in any case,
the Aristotelian statesmen goal will
be the restoration of the conditions of
constitutional government and rule of law
as quickly and again as efficiently as
possible. Uh, uh, net, uh, grim note,
uh, I think, uh, I let
you go and we will, uh,
conclude Aristotle next time.